und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mal
schießt bekomme ich schaden durch das
glas dpg
hallo ich in meiner lieben villiger bei
diesen herzlich willkommen zum traffics
folge hier am freitag die folge am
freitag unterscheidet sich wie immer mit
der folge am dienstag dass heute kein
geheimnisvolles geräusch tragen kommt
dann alle die meinten dass das
geheimnisvolle geholzt und blöd ist und
noch eine kurze sache bevor ich anfange
mit den fans und zwar kamen auch wieder
bei der letzten folge kommentare wie 00
auf 15 vergibt den namen von dem typen
vergessen der das so stolzen kommentare
geschrieben hatte dass er auch schon
alles wusste dass ich auch wenn sollte
mit der serie und dass ich so dumm bin
und gar nichts kann und immer nur sachen
vorstellen und ich könnte doch direkt
einfach vorstellen wie man ein crafting
table crafted also freunde noch mal im
leben gegenüber euch diese serie lebt
von ihren e-mails die mail zugesendet
werden und wenn ich dann sehe auch cool
das ist eine coole e mail die ist gut
aufgebaut ist von einer person die
bedankt sich dafür dass ich die serie
bleibt nadal ist schon mal die erste
bestanden heitz quote auf anderen
vorkommen dass wenn email jetzt drauf
gewartet mit 10 millionen rechts viele
leute kommen hier mal da sind dazu
verläuft vollidiot solche mails bekomme
ich auch die erste bestands probe und
die zweite ist dann ob der effekt ein
gutes und wenn der effekt mir gefällt
und ich sage hey das kannte ich noch gar
nicht das könnte man eventuell mal cool
vorstellen
dann nehme ich diesen effekt in der
folge mit dran und da kann ich natürlich
nicht immer dafür garantieren dass
dennoch keine person auf der welt kennt
irgendwer kennt immer ein fact und genau
ich mir kommt sofort genau diese
personen die es immer kennen sind immer
die gleichen und schreiben immer das
gleiche in die kommentare geben immer
einen dislike und sage ich gebe immer
das ergebnis total kaka bis total
unsympathisch gewahrt bleibt leute ich
erklärte nochmal das prinzip von youtube
ich bin auch kein angewiesen ich kann
machen was ich möchte und ich könnte
theoretisch auch fünfmal infekt
vorstellen dass man mit doppel
gesprintet
mal ganz grob genommen ich möchte nicht
böse mit euch sein aber es regt einheit
schon peter zeit so ein bisschen auf ich
mach die serie natürlich weiter an alle
die jetzt mal
so jetzt auch weil er immer so viel hält
kommt neben 99 feiern die serie das
sieht man ihr an den bewertungen aber
ich verstehe einfach nicht wie leute mir
quasi den mund verbieten so jahr stellt
das und das und das vor das ist totaler
schwachsinn was du machst also das ist
meine serie stellt das war was ich
möchte
die zweite sache ich kann natürlich
natürlich nicht dafür garantieren dass
ihr eventuell nicht schon alles kennt
was ich vorstellen oder dass er das
schon was andere videos kennen weil die
serie lebt von euren sachen die man
kräfte gmail.com zusendet milch steht in
der beschreibung und ich würde sagen wir
fangen mit dem ersten tag der mir
zugesagt wurde von yu-gi-oh starte und
zwar mir ein ganz normales mädchen
wir können ja ganz normal rechts
gedrückt halten rechtsklick gedrückt
halten und dann locken wir das ganze und
das blocken hals ein quasi einfach bei
creeper explosionen dass man dann da
irgendwie geschützt ist oder auch bei
angriffen es gibt ja dieses wir heißt es
hit bildblog so dass man so schnell
sondern irgendwie so ich kann das nicht
so gut macht man das überhaupt so ich
bin mir da nicht sicher glaubt man
schlägt und durch danach einmal blocken
oder irgendwie keine ahnung ist ja auch
vollkommen egal jedenfalls was damals so
dass wenn man das schwert in der hand
hatte und man jetzt so sich vorgehalten
hat halte ich jetzt genau von mikro aber
dass wenn ich das so vorgehalten habe
quasi direkt vor meinem körper so
richtig als schutz allerdings mit der
1.8 ist es so gekommen wenn ich mal
gedrückt halte ist das schwert nur noch
so halb vor dem körper das heißt es ist
quasi gar kein schutz so richtig vor dem
körper sondern es ist halt wirklich von
so dies damals war es zu so geworden der
schutz
es ist einfach eine total dumme neuerung
dass man das nicht mehr also so sieht
sie immer noch gleichauf mit dem mit dem
fonds halten aber wenn ich mal gerade
cook ist es quasi einfach nur so wie als
wenn ich mir vor meiner nase halte als
nicht das schwert ein bisschen anders
erhalte das ist sowieso ein angriff
quasi nicht so wirklich seine
verteidigung ist ein bisschen komisch
aber auf jeden fall cool das deuce
ausgefallenes wie bio statt und das
effekt nur 1,24 schon da steht wurde mit
dieser fällt nämlich zugesendet von
louis und zwar mit louis rohbau doch mal
hier so ein paar glasscheiben hin ich
habe da jetzt einfach
lust entgleisten genommen da können wir
beispielsweise orange purple magenta
pinguin breit blut netto habe ich keines
hätten irgendwelche anderen könnten wir
theoretisch themen einfach mal so eine
band bauern ich habe dass unsere vision
verziert mit fenstern und so habe ich
eine rats tonspur die geht nämlich ein
dispenser wo ein paar pfeile drin sein
da sind schon ein paar aus weil es
natürlich schon getestet habe und da
sind relativ viele fehler drin und ihr
kennt ist wenn ich jetzt drauf brücke
schießt der einfall gegen die wand und
wenn ich hierhin laufen kann ich den
fall einsammeln und ich geh jetzt mal
den game zu null und wir wissen ja ok
komm ich stehe hier hier so ich bin mir
eigentlich sicher weil ich bin ja nicht
in der wand blabla und das ganze mit
abgeblockter falsche dagegen und ich
sage mir die halt ein durch das glas und
gerade das ist es nämlich dieses glas
hat ich kann man halt blogger einsammeln
et cetera pp und man kann da auch selber
durchlaufen also wenn ihr jetzt mal so
schaut
ich gucke quasi so halb wenn ich euch
das mal anschaut ich gucke so halb mit
meinem arm hier kann man das ganz gut
sehen gucke ich so halb durch das glas
durch das geht bei keinem anderen blog
ich glaube bei es geht bei anderen
blöcken und zwar halt bei solchen sachen
wie halt auch irgendwie zäune oder bei
diesem stahl gitterstäben oder irgendwie
sowas
und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mal
schieße bekomme ich schaden durch das
glas durch wenn ich allerdings wieder
hier stehe wo ich nicht gegen wieder
drin bin dieser redbox dann bekomme ich
wieder nur den fall dagegen geschoss und
kann danach einsammeln aber hier bekomme
ich halt wieder schaden
also man kann quasi wenn man sich direkt
an ein glas payne stellt trotzdem
schaden bekommen finde ich irgendwie
doof sollte berichtigt werden
ich denke es ist kein bug sondern es ist
halt extra so wenn man halt so ein
bisschen dadurch guckt immer wenn man
sich da so dran stellt weil dieser block
relativ dünn ist und aber ich meine es
ist ja auch nicht so wenn ich die
theoretisch auch ein ganz kleines holz
blatt bei mir vor die
der holz blatt gar keine sind kleine
oder sagen einfach wenn ich mich an glas
stelle und jemand spielt mit dem
fußballer gegner bekomme ich auch keinen
schaden mehr oder weniger oder kriegt
den ball so direkt gegen seiner derzeit
hat auch ab und ich finde das sollte auf
jeden fall richtig werden aber es ist
cool das herausgefunden dass ruiz und
jetzt kommt der nächste act in nächst
effekt wurde mir nämlich zugesendet von
nico und zwar mein mikro wenn du ein
schickes post normal jetzt aber ihren
schicken und dann auf dieses chicken
eier drauf werfen
dann werden quasi diese hühnchen ich
mache das jetzt mal einfach diese
hühnchen die ich quasi die dann
gesprochen werden wenn ich das auf
dieses münchen bleibt man stehen bleibt
man stehen bleibt man stehen bleibt man
stehen bleibt man stehen
wieso bist wieso habe ich immer so
hyperaktive münchen wenn ich jetzt auf
jeden fall mal weiter fertig los mit
diesem ding
diese ist in dassow hyperaktiv
jedenfalls alle hühner die das ist
außerhalb der dings vom jedenfalls ist
dieses münchen es ist auch krasser sich
auf 20 minuten raus bekommen
das ist jetzt fokussiert auf die mutter
das heißt dass schwimmt jetzt zu der
mutter hin wenn diese mutter jetzt
wegschwimmt dann stimmt dieses münchen
dieser mutter gleich hinterher wir
können das ganze mal von hier oben
beobachten ganz cool so wir sehen jetzt
okay das kleine mädchen ist sehr sehr
langsam es bewegt sich aber es ist sehr
sehr langsam jedenfalls visiert dieses
kleine mädchen jetzt dieses große
hühnchen quasi als mutter an
doch aber man sieht glaube ich dass es
sich bewegt ja man sieht das ist auf
jeden fall worden das ist jetzt quasi
auf diese mutter visiert und wenn ich
diese mutter jetzt mal nicht klappen
wenn ich diese mutter jetzt irgendwie
mal hierhin schubse seht ihr schon der
de wit andere münchen auch darin
schwingt also dieses münchen hat dann
quasi seine mutter visierung auf dieses
teil wo ich das drauf geschmissen habe
und will dann immer wieder zurück zu
dieser mutter ich könnte das ganze jetzt
auch mal wieder drauf schubs ich weiß
gar nicht kommen diese kleinen hündchen
dieses teile hier hoch ja eigentlich
schon
und jetzt schwimmt deshalb wieder es
wird wieder die mutter an schwimmt der
mutter auf jeden fall entgegen und das
ist quasi so eine mutter funktion die
mir da der neo gezeigt hat
perfekt nummer 34 effekt wurde mir
zugesendet von johanna sie hat mir
außerdem auch ein bild geschickt wo sie
ein ananas shirt vor mir an hat das
wollte ich auch das anziehen aber es
sind knapp 30 grad unter angezogen es
ist krass ihr hat glaube ich das erste
bild mir geschickten anders drauf sonst
alle immer diesen schriftzug gekauft
also dass auf jeden fall cool und ja sie
hatten auf jeden fall effekt zugesendet
wenn ich ich mache es einfach mal vor
achtet macht die wolken dahinten das ist
total doof irgendwie man hat's cent in
der normalen welt also in dieser
oberwelt wenn ich den da platziere diese
teile sind einfach nur zur beleuchtung
zur verschönerung dann werden die ganze
dings vom rom als wenn man sich quasi
unter seinem blog stellt wird das also
als wenn ich mich jetzt hier so
unterstellen würde
da wird das ganze auch relativ dunkel
kommt drauf an was für blogger bei mir
wenn ich das mal so mache oder hier noch
so ein bisschen rambau ich denke das ist
eigentlich gar nicht effekte weht schon
das wird alles dunkel wieder hervorgehen
wird es wieder hell als tostedt ist es
aber im krassesten da springe ich quasi
drauf und alles sieht extrem dunkel als
ständig in seinem total düsteren viertel
und wenn ich dann hochspringer
beispielsweise ist wieder weg wenn ich
immer so ein bisschen drauf springen und
wenn ich jetzt komplett mal weggehen ist
quasi wieder normal hält
ich weiß nicht warum es sollte
vielleicht ein bisschen dieser hölle
darstellen und das sind auch totenköpfe
noch ein bisschen beängstigend schwarz
also nichts gegen schwarz erhält aber ja
ich weiß nicht warum das ganze so ist
wenn jetzt schreibt seine kommentare
dank an dich johanna für den effekt so
freundin kommt mit nummer 5 der mir
ebenfalls zugesetzt wurde von nico
eigentlich wollte ich diesen fake ja
auch noch in der anderen welt vorstellen
in dem hexenhäuschen allerdings ist mir
dabei aufgefallen
ich habe in dieser welt defekte schon
getestet deswegen funktioniert das ganze
nicht mehr so gut deswegen bin ich jetzt
hier in der komplett neu generierten
welt ich stelle jetzt einfach mal so ein
crafting table hin und ich habe hier
eine mtv könig zwicken und wir sehen was
ihr alles in der umgebung ist die zeit
da können wir ein bisschen rumlaufen
blabla und wenn jetzt denke ich möchte
ein bisschen irgendwie mal die welt
erkunden et cetera und so ein bisschen
hier so was raus finden wenn ich an
beispielsweise hier am rand bin gegen
laufe seht ihr einfach nur mal punkt ist
da vorne will ich jetzt wieder
zurückkaufe dann bin ich wieder auf der
map ich hoffe jetzt mal zu dem crafting
table und zeigt euch was man dann
nämlich machen kann gegen diese ganze
sache so ich bin richtig drauf packt die
map pack da einfach mal paper drumrum
bekomme hier eine neue map und ihr seht
bei dieser map sehe ich jetzt neue
sachen ich habe quasi diese als
schweinchen
ich habe quasi simmet vergrößert indem
ich da einfach paper drum umgelegt habe
ich weiß nicht wie bekannt dieses ding
schon ist ich habe es noch nicht gelesen
und wir hatten bei captain auch das
problem mit der map und da hat es uns
auch keiner geschrieben deswegen ich das
noch nicht so viele wissen allerdings
können wir jetzt einfach mal in diese
richtung da fliegen
so wir haben die map jetzt fertig
erkundet wenn ihr mal schaut oder ist
das ganze so ein bisschen der kunde das
ist jetzt alles auf jeden fall ein kunde
und jetzt ist nämlich die sache und zwar
hatte ich jetzt in der test wird
ausprobiert aber nicht so dass wir darin
rafting taylor gesetze und wir können
hier einfach mal uns neues ding holen
in meiner test hatte ich jetzt dass ich
sie jetzt nicht noch einmal größer
machen konnte ich probiere das ganze
jetzt hier mal mit euch so jetzt hab ich
nämlich wieder eine map und wir sehen ja
größer geht es wirklich nicht aber man
kann sie auf jeden fall noch größer
machen indem man also ich habe am anfang
schon gesehen ich hatte diese normale
web in der hand die habe ich komplett
erkundet dann hab ich doch herbert
umgelegt und die map wurde quasi
erweitert größer geht es wohl wirklich
nicht weil das ganze dann wahrscheinlich
auch ein bisschen zu groß werden würde
dann würde man immer nur noch so kleine
flüsse seen und keine ahnung
man kann ja nicht unendlich viel größer
machen deswegen würde ich sagen auf
jeden fall das perfekte fünf man kann
die fag einmal größere man kann defekt
man kann ihn map einmal größer machen
wenn ihr wisst wie das eventuell ein
weiteres mal geht schreibt in kommentare
schreibt mir außerdem eventuelle in die
kommentare wie euch das gefallen hat ich
gebe mir in letzter zeit echt immer mehr
mühe bei den sechs folgen was die
bearbeitung angeht und außerdem was die
fakten angeht da ist kann einfach mal
ein schwein gestorben mich gehört es
auch egal jedenfalls meinen bestimmt
wieder sehr viele leute ich kannte schon
alles um global aber dafür kann ich halt
nichts freunde
es ist halt schortens und sorry sorry da
sie am anfang ein bisschen böse mit war
aber es ist halt wirklich youtube
broadcast yourself macht das was du
willst hat das hochfest du willst und
ich möchte da nicht nur weil leute mal
die steuern mal andere facts vorstelle
ich nicht unbedingt andere effekte wenn
ihr allerdings cool effect schreibt mir
per mail an kommen kräfte gmail.com
bewertet das video bittere ich denke
wieder dass es eine menge deshalb
bekommen weil ihre serie in als ein
bisschen im schlechten rampenlicht steht
ist doch alles sagen soll ich hoffe dass
mein iphone 6 heute noch ankommt weil
ich sie schon vor vier wochen
vorgestellt habt mir geht's super gut
hier sind 30 grad ich leider viel zu
viel schwachsinn
ok